The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Today we try to wrap up
our present discussion
of partial derivatives by means
of a rather practical example,
which not only has
wide application
but which ties in many of
the individual principles
that we've talked about in the
last two blocks of material.
The particular topic
that I have in mind today
is the topic known as the theory
of maxima/minima of functions
in several variables.
You see, in part
one of our course
we studied the
special case where
we had a function from the real
numbers into the real numbers.
And what we were
looking for were
values of the independent
variable for which f
was either maximum or minimum.
And so a natural extension of
this is simply the following:
given a real-valued function
of several real variables--
in other words, assume that f
is a mapping from n-dimensional
space into the real numbers, f
is a function from E^n into E.
Then the n-tuple a bar, in E sub
n, is called a local maximum--
and I suppose we might as
kill two birds with one stone
here and put in the
definition for a local minimum
at the same time.
It's called a local
maximum of f if and only
if there exists a neighborhood
n of a bar such that f of a bar
is greater than or equal to
f of x bar for every x bar
in the neighborhood.
I suppose, by the
way, while we're
at this, for a local minimum
the condition would be what?
For a local minimum,
instead of f of a bar
being greater than or equal to f
of x bar, it would be less than
or equal to.
In other words,
what you're saying
is that what you mean by a
local high point or low point
is what?
That in a neighborhood
of the point in question,
for example, if
that output exceeds
every other possible output
in a sufficiently small
neighborhood, then we say
that that particular input
is the local maximum.
And a similar definition
for local minimum.
In other words,
again, keep in mind
that this is
precisely and almost
a word-for-word translation
of what the terms relative
maximum and relative minimum
or local max and local min
meant for functions of
a single real variable.
Consequently, except for the
fact that in several variables
it's much more difficult
to describe domains because
of all the degrees of
freedom that you have,
one would expect that these same
particular tests for membership
would occur for functions
of several variables
when we're looking for high-low
points or max-min points
as in the case of one
independent variable.
So let's just very
quickly summarize this.
How do we test for candidates
for max-min points?
Now, the idea is simply
this, that if we're
going to have a relative
high or a relative low point,
think of the thing graphically.
If you take a cross section
with respect to any one
of the independent variables.
In other words, if you look at
f as a function just of x_1,
say, and hold x_2
up to x_n constant,
then when w is viewed as
a function of x_1 alone,
then one would expect
that you have what?
That just in the w,x_1-plane,
you must have a candidate,
which means that one would
expect that if you took
the partial of f with respect
to x_1, that must be 0.
Similarly, the partial
of f with respect to x_2
must be 0, et cetera.
The partial of f with
respect to x sub n must be 0.
In other words, to find a
candidate for a max-min point,
notice that right
off the bat we're
back to a practical application
of the study of systems
of several equations
in several unknowns.
Namely, we must solve
the systems of equations
the partial of f with respect
to x_1 equals 0, et cetera,
the partial of f with
respect to x_n equals 0.
Find simultaneous
solutions, whenever
such simultaneous
solutions exist.
Now of course, there may
be points in our domain
where the partials
don't exist, just
like there was in the case of
calculus of a single variable.
In other words, the second thing
we do in testing for candidates
is we find points in the domain
where f is not differentiable.
For example, f might
not be continuous.
f might not be defined.
Whatever the reason
is, we look to see
where f is not differentiable.
And all points in the domain at
which f is not differentiable,
they also become candidates
for max-min points.
And thirdly, we check the
boundary of the domain of f.
In other words,
if the domain of f
happens to be a
two-dimensional region,
we check the boundary
of the region.
Again, the reason being
the same as in the calculus
of a single real variable.
If a function is
differentiable, it
must take on its maximum
and minimum values
some place, if
the domain happens
to be a closed set, in
other words, a connected set
with a boundary.
And we won't go into
that in any more
detail at this particular time.
But essentially, what do we do?
We look at the function
wherever it's differentiable,
take all of its partials,
set them equal to 0,
solve that system simultaneously
to see what values of x_1
up to x_n give us permissible
candidates for max-min points,
we check to see where the
derivative does not exist,
and that gives us
another batch of points,
and then we check
the boundary values
to see if anything
peculiar happens there.
Same three tests as we had for
calculus of a single variable.
And why is this
so closely allied
to calculus of a
single variable?
Well, if we take
the case n equals 2,
we again get a nice
geometric interpretation.
Namely, if w is a
function of x and y,
notice again our
notation for what
happens when we have two
independent variables.
They're called x and
y, and usually we
let the dependent variable
be w in that case.
Let's take a look and see
what happens over here.
Suppose, for the
sake of argument,
that we know that we
have a relative low point
corresponding to
the input a comma b.
In other words, suppose we
know that f of a comma b
is the lowest value of f, the
lowest height on the surface,
in a sufficiently small
neighborhood of the point
a comma b.
All I'm saying is this:
take any slice whatsoever,
any plane through the point a
comma b, pick any direction s.
Take that plane
perpendicular to the xy-plane
in the s direction,
and slice the surface w
equals f of x, y
with that plane,
and we get a slice
something like this.
Not something like this, this
is the slice that we get.
Now, let's take a look at
where that low point is.
Since that is to be a low
point in the entire region,
obviously it must be a
low point, in particular,
with respect to the
particular slice that we took.
How could it be the
lowest point every place
if it's not the lowest
point with respect
to any particular slice?
And all we're saying
then is that with respect
to this slice, notice that
w is a function of s alone.
In other words, we can
talk about the directional
derivative df/ds.
And again, all we're saying is
that directional derivative,
df/ds, evaluated at
the point a comma b,
must be 0 for all directions s.
And as we have seen
throughout our course,
if f happens to be a
continuously differentiable
function of the
variables x_1 up to x_n,
then the directional derivative
is determined completely
by our knowledge of the partials
with respect to x_1 up to x_n.
And you see, as far as
the theory is concerned,
that's all there is to it.
As the cliche goes,
the rest is commentary.
Now what kind of
commentary do I mean?
Well, among other
things, once we
have located all the particular
max-min candidates-- see,
notice why I call these
things candidates.
All we're saying
is that wherever
the system of
possible derivatives,
setting them equal
to 0, yields a value,
that point is simply a
candidate for a max-min point.
Just, again, like in the
calculus of a single variable.
If f prime of a is 0, we cannot
conclude that a is a local max
or a local min. it
might be a saddle point,
a stationary point where
the thing just levels off.
It's just that once
we have the candidate,
how do we test whether it
really is a max or a min?
Well, what we have to do is,
looking at f of a comma b,
we have to see whether that's
the lowest possible value
or the highest possible
value in a sufficiently small
neighborhood of that point.
Well, how do you characterize
a neighborhood of the point?
You look at some nearby point,
which we can denote as what?
a plus h comma b plus k.
As if this h and k
seem strange to you,
notice that h is often
what we call delta x,
and k is what we
often call delta y.
In other words, we look at some
nearby point, a plus delta x
comma b plus delta y.
And what we're saying
is that if this
is to be, for
example, a high point,
it means that when you
compute this difference,
this difference had better
be negative all the time.
Because when you look at this
particular thing over here,
if this is to be the
greatest possible value
in a neighborhood
when you subtract it
from something else
in the neighborhood,
you should get a negative value.
In other words, to put it
in still other terms, what
we're saying is that to--
let's just read this again.
Once a max-min candidate
a comma b is found,
we must investigate the sign
of f of a plus h comma b
plus k minus f of a, b for
all sufficiently small values
of h and k.
OK?
That's for all sufficiently
small values of h of k,
which can be messy.
I don't mean that.
I mean for all sufficiently
small values of h and k,
in other words,
in a neighborhood
of the point a comma b.
And what I'm saying is that
this particular computation
can itself be very messy.
You see?
This is, again, going back
to this idea of how we
invert equations and the like.
It's difficult to compute f
of a plus h comma b plus k,
in general, if f is
a messy function,
if f is a computationally
complicated thing.
And not only that, but we
may have several unknowns,
more than two unknowns.
And you see, this was
true in one variable.
We saw in the case of one
variable that, technically
speaking, to test
whether f of a was
a high point of a
low point, we had
to look at f of a plus h minus
f of a for all sufficiently
small values of h.
And that could have been
a messy computation too.
Of course, the thing that
happened in the single variable
that was very helpful to
us was that in the case
of a single variable,
we were often
able to use f double
prime of a as a hint.
In other words, whenever
f double prime of a
wasn't equal to 0, we can
conclude, or could conclude,
whether f of a was
a max or min, once
we know that f prime of a was 0.
Remember, that was
that holding water
versus spilling water routine.
If f double prime
of a was positive,
that meant that the
curve was holding water.
Holding water meant that
you had a minimum value.
If f double prime
of a was negative,
that meant that the
curve was spilling water.
And spilling water
yielded a maximum value.
And the only problem was, is
when the second derivative
was 0, in which case
the test failed.
What did it mean
that the test failed?
When f double prime of
a was 0, the only way
we could test to see
whether a was a max or a min
on neither, meaning
a saddle point,
what was to actually look at
f of a plus h minus f of a
and see what happened
in that particular case.
Now, one would like to believe
that an analogous result held
for the case of
several real variables,
in particular for the case
of two independent variables.
The point is that in a
manner of speaking, it does.
But in another
manner of speaking,
things are much more
complicated than what
happened in the case of
one independent variable.
In particular, what goes
wrong is the following,
and that is that the
second derivative,
in the case of two
independent variables,
involves three
separate partials.
See what do you mean
by a second derivative?
You mean you must
differentiate something twice.
Well, you could've
differentiated
the function twice with respect
to x at the point a comma b.
That's what we mean
by f sub xx, recall.
Or you might have differentiated
first with respect
to x and then with respect
to y, in which case
it would have been f
sub xy of a comma b.
In fact, I should
be careful here.
There should be a
fourth one here too,
and that is f sub y,x.
Namely, first differentiate
with respect to y and then
with respect to x.
The reason I left
that out over here
was simply because, if we
have a nice function, meaning
one that's continuous, and the
derivatives are continuous,
and the mixed derivatives
exist and are continuous,
we showed that the
order in which we
take the partials made no
difference, that f sub xy
was equal to f sub yx.
But getting back to this
idea, the third possibility
is that you can have
differentiated twice
with respect to y and formed
and f sub yy of a comma b.
And so the question is, with all
of these different second-order
partial derivatives
floating around,
what do you mean by the
second partial derivative?
And the key
expression, and I think
this is far from intuitive,
but the key expression
turns out to be that the
determining factor is
the second partial with
respect to x, in other words f
sub xx, multiplied by the second
partial with respect to y, f
sub yy, minus the square
of the mixed partial.
And that particular factor,
the sine of that factor,
determines whether you have a
maximum point, a minimum point,
a saddle point, or else
the test might fail.
By the way, this is a rather
difficult proof to come by.
The proof is done in chapter
18 of the Thomas text,
and is assigned for you.
I tried to give you learning
exercises that take you
through the proof step by step.
And I have also included an
optional supplementary lecture
for those of you who may still
have difficulty following
both the text and the
supplementary notes
and the learning exercises,
because it's all written out
and might like to
hear the thing spoken.
What I will do is
derive this for you
in an optional lecture for
those of you who want it.
But for the time being,
to give us our overview,
let me simply state
what the properties
of this particular quantity are.
That the main result-- and as I
just write here to remind you,
that the details
are derived later,
both in the text, in
the learning exercises,
and in an optional lecture--
that suppose we have solved
our simultaneous
system and have found
points a comma b,
where the partial
of f with respect to x and the
partial of f with respect to y
equals 0.
So we now have a
candidate, meaning
a comma b now is eligible to be
tested to see whether it yields
a maximum or a minimum value.
The test turns out to be this,
you compute f sub xx times
f sub yy minus f sub xy
squared at the point a comma b.
And if that particular number
turns out to be greater than 0,
then a comma b yields
a local minimum
of f if f sub xx
happens to be positive,
and a local maximum if f sub
xx happens to be negative.
Now, the easiest
way to remember that
is to think in terms of a
partial derivative, again.
Imagine that we've sliced the
surface so that we're looking
at a cut in the wx-plane.
In the wx-plane, notice that
if the second derivative of w
with respect to x
is positive, that
means that the curve
is holding water.
And holding water seems to
indicate a minimum, you see.
And similarly, if it's
negative it's spilling water,
and that would
indicate a maximum.
You might say, what happens
if f sub xx happens to be 0.
And the answer is, lookit,
if f sub xx happens to be 0,
this case couldn't have
occurred in the first place,
because if f sub
xx happens to be 0,
this term drops
out, in which case
this could not be a
positive expression.
With this term missing, the
smallest the square can be
is 0, and a negative of a
positive or non-zero number
can't be negative.
In other words, you could
not obey this inequality
if f sub xx happened to be 0.
If you want to argue,
why couldn't you
look at f sub yy instead of f
sub xx, the answer is, f sub xx
and f sub yy must both
have the same sign.
Because if we just
look at this thing,
notice that this term
has to be positive.
You're subtracting off
something positive,
therefore the term
you're subtracting from
must be positive.
And the only way the product
of two numbers can be positive
is if each of the factors
has the same sign.
But again, I don't
want to belabor that.
I just want to go through this
thing fairly rapidly with you.
It turns out, by the way, if
this key factor, this key term,
f sub xx f sub yy minus the
square of the mixed partial,
happens to be negative,
then you can be sure
that you have a saddle point.
In other words,
what that means is
for any neighborhood
of the point
a comma b, for some values of
f, for some values of x comma
y in that neighborhood, the
function will be greater than f
of a comma b, and for others
it will be less than f
of a comma b.
So it's neither a max nor a min.
And it turns out that the
situation in which to test
fails is if this particular
expression happens to equal 0.
So again, you see that from
a purely mechanical point
of view, this test is
rather easy to memorize.
The hard part is the proof.
And that's why,
as I say, there's
extra drill on that part, if you
happen to be interested in it.
And by the way, if you're
not interested in it,
skip the proof.
In fact, for the
sake of this course,
I am not concerned with how well
you handle max-min problems.
I'm interested more
in showing you overall
what max-min
problems mean and how
all of the principles of
partial differentiation
seem to come up in that
particular application
of max-min problems.
So from a theoretical
point of view,
that would complete
the study of how
one handles max-min problems,
except that an even more
difficult and subtle form
of computational difficulty
comes up, in terms of some
of the practical applications
that we have, which
motivate such mechanical and
computational devices
known as, for example,
the Lagrange multipliers and
things of this sort that,
again, are discussed in the text
and in the learning exercises
and which I will not discuss
in the lecture, other
than to motivate for
you why they occur.
And let me just finish up
today's lesson in terms of one
more topic.
And this is a bad
name for this topic,
because we've already used this
word in a different context.
But this very often
happens in mathematics,
that the same word is used
in more than one context.
But one often talks
about constraints
when one deals with functions
of several variables.
In other words,
in many cases when
one wants to
maximize or minimize
a function of
several variables, it
turns out that certain
external conditions
happen to be imposed.
Now, if that sounds like
a difficult mouthful
to comprehend, I would
like to start off
with an example that's
already occurred
in a max-min problem in
part one of our course,
but in such a subtle
way that we never
noticed that it was really
involving a function
of several variables.
In fact, if it hadn't
have been that subtle,
we'd have been in
trouble, because in part
one of our course, we did
not talk about functions
of more than one real variable.
But for example, let's revisit
a type of problem that says
let's find the minimum
distance, say, from the origin,
0 comma 0, the minimum distance
from the origin to the curve
x*y equals 1.
Well, to find that
minimum distance,
notice that what we have to
do is minimize a distance
function, namely the
square of the distance--
I use the square simply to
eliminate the square root
sign here-- the square of
the distance from the origin
to any point x comma y is
x squared plus y squared.
Well, notice that
in this form, this
is a function of two
independent variables.
The trouble is, you don't want
the distance from the origin
to any old point.
The point that you're
investigating has to be
on the curve x*y equals 1.
And that means that x and
y, for your investigation
in this problem,
are not independent.
Namely, x and y are related.
Now by the way, sometimes this
equation can be so messy that
we cannot solve for y
explicitly in terms of x.
In this particular case,
as long as x is not 0,
we can solve specifically for
y in terms of x, in which case
we get y equals 1 over x.
And that is, in
this particular case
then, the function that
we want to minimize,
even though it looks
like a function of two
independent variables,
is really a function
of one independent
variable, because since y
is equal to 1 over x in our
investigation, f of x comma y
is really f of x comma 1 over x.
In other words, going back
to what f is explicitly
in this case, f of x comma y
is just x squared plus 1 over x
quantity squared.
And that in turn is also
just a function of x.
Now you see, what makes
this thing more difficult
is, first of all, we may not be
dealing with a function of just
two variables to minimize.
And secondly, we may have a very
difficult constraint imposed.
Or what makes things
even more difficult
is that if we have to
minimize a function,
say, a five variables, there
may be two or three or even
four constraints imposed.
And the question is, how
do you maximize or minimize
a function, taking
into consideration
the fact that there are
constraints imposed?
And this is what brings up
all of the type of material
that I gave you as
exercises in the last unit,
where we talked about
the Jacobian matrix,
and handled the
inverting systems,
and how we could solve
explicitly or implicitly
for functions, implicit
function theorems,
things that we talked
about in those exercises.
All of those things come up
in solving max-min problems
in several unknowns.
See, more generally,
what we're saying
is we have more
variables than two,
and we have more
implicit constraints,
meaning more constraints than
just a single constraint,
and also using more variables,
and also more involving
modifying implicit that
you just can't solve
for one of the
variables explicitly
in terms of the other,
even though there
is an implicit
relationship involved.
Now, I hate to work
abstractly in general,
but in this particular
lecture I'm going to do that.
I'm going to talk with
you abstractly here,
but all of the exercises will
deal with concrete situations
so that you'll see all
of the theory come alive
in the problems.
But because I want to give
you the material as compactly
as possible, let me just
state what the situation is.
For example, suppose we
want to maximize or minimize
a function of what appears to
be three independent variables,
say, f of x, y, z.
And all of a sudden,
somebody tells us,
hey, in the domain that we're
interested in, x, y, and z
are not independent.
There's a certain constraint.
And let's write
that symbolically
as some function of
x, y, and z equals 0.
Remember, that's
simply our abstract way
of saying that there is some
functional relationship that
relates x, y, and z.
And we'll simply call that
g of x, y, z equals 0.
Maybe I could solve for z
explicitly in terms of x and y
from this particular
relationship.
Maybe I can.
But at any rate, what we
do know from the learning
exercises of last time,
that g of x, y, z equals 0,
will implicitly define z as
some function of x and y,
say k of x, y,
except in that case
where the partial of g with
respect to z happens to be 0.
And I put this thing
in parentheses for you
simply to give you
motivation to review
the exercises of last time if
this seems a bit vague to you.
At any rate, what this
thing means in plain English
is that subject
to the constraint,
that z is some
function of x and y.
We take this constraint,
we put that back
into our original function
that we're trying to maximize.
Notice that f of x, y, z now
becomes f of x, y, k of x, y.
See? z is k of x, y.
If we now look at
this expression,
notice only x and y appear, so
that subject to the constraint
g of x, y, z equals
0, the function f
is a function of only two
independent variables,
not three.
And to indicate that, let's
simply say that f of x, y,
z-- f of x, y, k of
x, y in this case--
is some function h of x and y.
And what our problem
is now saying
is, minimize or
maximize the function
h, which is a function of
two independent variables.
Now notice here--
it's been quite a
while since we've dealt
with the chain rule--
but notice here that the
chain rule now comes up
in a very important practical
application, namely,
this looks like an eyesore
f of x, y comma k of x, y.
How can we handle that?
Notice that another
way of saying this,
utilizing the chain rule, is
to say h of x, y is f of x, y,
z where z is some
function k of x and y.
See, f is a function
of x, y and z,
and z is a function of x and y.
In fact, if you wanted
to say it another way,
you could say what?
f is some function of x, y, z,
where x equals x, y equals y,
and z equals k of x, y.
You see?
That's your
particular chain rule.
Now, lookit.
See, this is, again, one of
the problems of mathematics,
which I hope is crystal
clear by this time.
Granted, that we discussed
the chain rule in block three.
That's no reason why in
block four we can beg off
and say, we had a long time
ago, I don't remember that.
No.
Hopefully, we've made
the chain rule so clear
that any time I tell you
that we have to invoke it,
you can just write it
down very, very quickly.
How does the chain
rule work now?
To differentiate
this with respect
to x, say, we take
the partial of this
with respect to x, times the
partial of x with respect to x,
plus the partial
of f with respect
to y times the partial
of y with respect
to x, plus the partial of
f with respect to z times
the partial of z
with respect to x.
In other words, the general
theory hasn't changed at all.
To maximize or minimize
h, what we're going to do
is we're going to take the
partial of h with respect
to x and set that
equal to 0, we're
going to take the partial
of h with respect to y
and set that equal
to 0, and solve
that system simultaneously.
But the hard point
computationally
is, sure, you can say let's
set the partials is equal to 0.
But before you can do
that, you had better
be able to take the partials.
And that's where the
computationally skill comes in.
So how do we take the partial
of h with respect to x here?
Well, we just said that.
The partial of h with respect
to x, using the chain rule,
is f sub x times the partial
of x with respect to x, plus f
sub y times the partial of y
with respect to x, plus f sub
z times the partial of
z with respect to x.
Now notice that the partial
of x with respect to x is 1.
So that gives me f
sub x over there.
Keep in mind that whereas z
is a function of x and y--
let's go back here and take
a quick look at that-- notice
that in our function
h, we're assuming what?
That x and y are the
independent variables,
but that z is a
function of x and y.
The point, therefore,
is that since x and y
are independent
variables, by definition
that means that the partial
of y with respect to x is 0.
In other words, the fact
that y and x are independent
means that the change in y
with respect to a change in x
is 0, because we can change
x without changing y.
And finally, given
that z is k of x, y,
we can compute the partial
of z with respect to x.
And so, what we wind up with
is that the partial of h
with respect to x is the
partial of f with respect to x,
plus the partial of f
with respect to z times
the partial of z with respect x.
And we must set that equal to 0.
Again, leaving the details to
you as a review of the chain
rule.
In a similar way, we show that
the partial of h with respect
to y is the partial of
f with respect to y,
plus the partial of
f with respect to z,
times the partial of
z with respect to x,
and we set that equal to 0.
Now, the thing to keep in mind
is to observe that f of x, y, z
was a given function.
We know what that looks like.
Consequently, these four
quantities are known.
The trouble is that
g of x, y, z equals 0
defines z implicitly as
a function of x and y.
And consequently,
if it turns out
that we could not have
solved our system for z
explicitly in terms of x
and y, the question mark
would be, for example--
I'm sorry.
This is a misprint over here.
This should be, of course,
the partial of-- we're
differentiate with respect to y.
This is the partial of
f with respect to y,
plus the partial of
f with respect to z,
times the partial of
z with respect to y.
The key point over here is
simply that we must know what?
If we can't solve for z
explicitly in terms of x and y,
how do we know what
these two quantities are?
We only know them implicitly.
And this gives us
our review, again,
of setting differentials
equal to 0 and the like.
Namely, if g of x, y,
z is identically 0,
we can equate the derivative
on both sides to 0.
And to differentiate
this thing implicitly,
it's, again, using the
chain rule, we get what?
The partial of g with respect
to x, plus the partial
of g with respect to z,
times the partial of z
with respect to x is 0.
Notice, by the way, that
g is given explicitly.
We're told what the function
g of x, y, z looks like.
Consequently, these
things here are known.
And we can now solve for the
partial of z with respect to x.
In fact, what is the partial
of z with respect to x?
That's nothing more than what?
It's minus the partial
of g with respect
to x divided by the partial
of g with respect to z.
And that's why the partial
of g with respect to z
had better not be 0, otherwise
we wind up in trouble here.
Similarly, we can find what the
partial of z with respect to y
is.
That's going to
turn out to be what?
Minus the partial
of g with respect
to y divided by the partial
of g with respect to z.
Knowing what these two values
are from these two equations,
we come back into the here.
And now we know what
these are, and now
we simply have all of
the known functions
on the right-hand side,
and we solve this system.
Now hopefully, this
is one of the times
I hope things don't
sound too clear to you,
meaning you have an
overview, but you
begin to suspect that this
is a very messy situation.
Because, you see, what
I wanted you to see
is that solving such
a system like this
can be extremely cumbersome.
And that's why, in the
exercises, we do two things.
We have to solve
systems like this
to get the experience
of seeing that there's
a big difference between
knowing theoretically
how to solve a
system of equations
and knowing pragmatically
how to carry it out.
And secondly, we hope that
some of these computations
become cumbersome enough
so that you practically
beg to find some shortcuts.
Because if you're not
begging to find a shortcut,
then such things as
Lagrange multipliers
and the like, which
are techniques
for solving max-min problems
subject to constraints,
that those shortcuts
don't appeal to you
and you fail to see
their significance,
and you say, why do I have
to learn these things.
Don't I have enough
problems without it?
You see, again, notice the
difference between what's
happening here
abstractly and what's
happening computationally.
Abstractly, the
theory of max-min
is not that difficult. But
computationally, to handle it,
you have to be extremely
adept at handling systems
of n equations and n
unknowns, not necessarily
linear equations, being
able to throw in constraints
and seeing what's
happening here.
And at any rate, that's
what the learning exercises
will be all about, and
the material in the text.
And I think that's enough
of a mouthful for this time.
So until next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.